welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we want to study the
decay of a particle in this case the
decay of a
the pion is a particle which consists of
quarks and antiquarks which are bound
together by gluons they are part of the
family of particles which are called
mesons
and they can be charged and neutral so
we have positively charged negatively
charged and neutral
in this example we look at the neutral
ion decay and the specific decay into an
electron and a positron
mostly
neutral ions decay into a pair of
photons but we study this effect here
because it's more fun
the lifetime or the mean lifetime of a
pi zero is h times 10 to the
uh minus 17 seconds so when we produce
neutral pions in our detector they're
immediately k as i said mostly
into a pair of photons
let me just covered in the
1940s
um
and so let's get to it so the mass of a
pion of a neutral pion is 135 mev so
it's much heavier than an electron
uh which is 500 has a
mass of 511 kav
so we're looking at this decay here
there's a pioneer
yeah the pioneer at rest into an
electron and a positron and so the
charge for you now is to find the gamma
factor of the electron or the positron
or with that the velocity of those
particles in the decay of a pie island
rest
so again
as usual stop the video and try to work
this out
and again what we want to do is just
write down the four vector of the
particles involved we start with the
pion which has an energy of the pi and
mass times c square and at rest in this
example here
which means that the momentum is zero
and so then the outgoing particles are
the electron and the positron with their
energy and their momentum
and then just from this first line here
from the energy relation
you can
by knowing that the mass of the electron
and the deposits are not the same
but knowing that the gamma factor is the
same that comes out of the momentum
relation here that they have the same
velocity we can just simply find gamma
is equal to the pion mass divided by 2
times the electron mass and that is
about 132
all right so again we studied the decay
of a pion
and as a general example of a decay of a
particle into two
to new particles we use the energy
momentum relation we make sure
use of the fact in this case that we are
in the rest frame of the pile and then
we are able to
get to the velocity or the gamma factor
of the outgoing particles